well let them eat kate that was the
clear message from the met gardener last
night as the real world deals with the
brutal war a deadly pandemic and soaring
fl inflation billionaire irritant kim
kardashian
led the ostentatious showing off in new
york uh as she turned up in marilyn
monroe's five million dollar happy
birthday mr president dress
um miss kardashian said that she cried
when she realized she didn't fit into
the dress yeah maybe cry about something
a bit more worthwhile in the world would
be my advice for her but i'm going to
bring in melissa rivers now uh to
discuss all this melissa hey great to
talk to you how are you hi pierce how
good how are you it's been a long time i
lost all your celebrity apprentice with
our old friend donald trump
yes yes i think we've actually seen each
other one or two more times since then
but i think that's probably the most
memorable
let's talk met gala here's my view of
this i just felt it all look so
inappropriate to me a bunch of wealthy
celebrities turning up in ridiculous
outfits all costing tens of thousands of
dollars uh led by kim kardashian in a
five million dollar marilyn dress which
she shouldn't have been allowed to wear
all showing off how rich and famous and
loaded they are and so on and privileged
at a time when we have a war a pandemic
and surging inflation tone death
by so i guess we know now how you feel
am i wrong
okay i don't think you're necessarily
wrong but let's just roll back for a sec
first of all the fashion industry was
decimated
during covid
and it's not just about the designers
it's about the people that make the
dresses and make the fabric and the
mills and the people who build them so
there's a whole other part of the
industry that people don't see how can
they spend so much money melissa and yet
so many of them look so awful but
they're not paying for it it's all true
they turn up some of them turned i mean
kylie jenner turned up in this wedding
dress and baseball cap apparently had 80
people to pack her into it i mean
utterly ridiculous
i i'm not saying they're all good but it
really is and i understand completely
what you're saying and this was a big
discussion around the bringing back of
the oscars and all these things
but it is a night that
yes there it's supposed to be incredibly
over the top
the the kylie thing i did not understand
one iota
maybe i'm too old to go was it all about
low melissa i mean when you've got a
bunch of kardashians emily ratachowski
finally keeping some clothes on you've
got one of the beckham kids who's only
famous because his dad kicked a football
it all looked very low rent there was no
beyonce no rihanna no lady gaga just a
bunch of reality stars and footballers
sons
well that's been a big debate
about a number of high-end magazines and
who they're using in the magazines as
well as people who are would never
10 years ago would have been invited and
there's a big debate within the fashion
industry of that's appropriate but if
you go back kind of to my original point
these are the people that get attention
and it's a night to promote fashion
which is a
you know multi-billion dollar industry
here's
but then you get someone wait like rizzo
med
like rizzomed who i know people are like
oh i can't believe you wore that i
thought what he wore was brilliant
because he came out and said this is
representing the people the workers you
don't see
and i thought that was so smart
and so on but i would take you back to
what you just said well you said that a
lot of them are there because they get
attention and it seems to me that it
personifies the modern day celebrity
curse where people like the kardashians
the beckham's kids
emily radochansky all these people
they're not actually talented in their
own right they're just there because
they get attention
and celebrity used to be in the days of
marilyn monroe when she actually wore
that dress and sang to president kennedy
that was an amazing moment because she
was a proper movie star
these i
this look traipsing up the carpet last
night they're not proper stars they're
just wanna be attention seekers
but this is also a major
um discussion on a totally different
topic which i'm always happy to have
with you because i'm very much of two
minds about it
there's the business mind and then
there's sort of the hollywood history
of talent it's the talent mind and
there's the untalented company i mean
there's two types
if you do an episode on that you and i
could have a phenomenal conversation
about it and we can get super academic
and granular
so you and i would have a great time i
just don't think we can discuss the
kardashians and use the phrase super
super academic but we got to leave it
there uh melissa love me to talk to you
come back let's talk about celebrity
culture next time because i've got a lot
of strong views about it
anytime i'm there for you great to talk
to you all the very best
you